[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
have an incredibly important topic that
we're gonna be talking about today it's
our first time talking about it on the
show we are gonna be talking about
uplifting rural India and we have Maya
vishal karma joining us thank you so
much thank you so much for having me
here
thank you yes I'm very happy that you're
coming on to the show you're leading so
many important initiatives and we're
gonna be talking about them very excited
so before we talk about the saqqara
foundation and your work that you're
doing in rural india I want to get to
know your story along the journey so you
grew up in a village called met Oregon
right how do I say it it's gone never
gone and and so then as you you grew up
there I want to know what it was like
growing up there and then I want to know
why you came here ten years ago yes it's
interesting you know so in India like in
America you're from like I came to South
Dakota just like a rural part of India
and pretty much tribal we can say so I
grew up in tired village and growing up
there I learn a lot of I mean my family
my father was a farmer he still Pharma
and blacksmith and carpenter and we used
to have all the farming things and we
used to grow crops even I walked in the
field and we didn't had any kind of
water supply to our home so we used to
take water from the river directly from
the river so we did Simmons and and we
did all our work in the rivers in those
days because water was not there at home
no boring in the villages or or anything
so this was like a pretty much like all
the stories from
all the villages in India so I grew up
and I went to government school and
their school is like pretty much two
three rooms and fifty students are going
there and sometimes you have to clean
and you have to organize everything by
ourselves because there are few teachers
so in those school I went and it you
don't have to pay anything it's a prize
it's a government school but it's pretty
crazy State because you don't have a
formal classes or something like a very
nice sitting things or you have to sit
on the floor and clean your stuff and
everything but that was a really great
learning and I was very lucky I would I
would say because I came out and from
that village to other village to get my
- next two-year education which was my
uncle pays because I had only eighth
grade school in that village even still
is a eighth to tenth grade now and two
year and then again two year high school
somewhere and then college somewhere and
then slowly I went to big cities with
there I started learning so many things
hey this world is beautiful it's totally
different from my village where I grew
up and my family was very supportive
because my mother she always had a dream
that my daughter should go to school and
she should get a good education even
though she's not educated and she's my
dad also he's not he just went to high
school not even high school like a fifth
grade in our villages so that that is
like my family dream that they gave me
that freedom like we have only girl with
the three boys so we will raise her like
a boys it's a very rare in India
especially in Indian community that girl
can go outside of the village and get
the education so because they gave me
that freedom so I had that courage that
hey I had to do something I had to
really study hard and then I did my I
mean I supported myself I took a tuition
for the kids where I used to get little
money for my books and all in the city
is called Jabalpur where I was doing my
undergrad and after undergrad because I
want to become a doctor in child
but we don't have an enough money to pay
the tuitions and all that stuff so I
gave up that dream but I still pursue
that science stream that I really want
to become a scientist
so my undergrad was in biology and then
later I did a super specialization in
biochemistry Master in biochemistry from
India Jabalpur University but the last
semester we had to go anywhere in India
anywhere means like the big Institute
you can explore and do your thesis
dissertation work and I was lucky enough
to go to one of the best medical college
in India which is a Stanford of of India
called All India Institute of Medical
Science Ames New Delhi
so when I went there the world is
totally different because my study was
different I I did all my education in
Hindi medium I I had English like a very
very you know one subject only in after
high school actually so the language was
an issue like you had to study in
English and he had to speak and then you
had to learn computer so but I was like
you know very hardworking and I got a
good books and Internet and all that
stuff which I learn in in New Delhi and
later I came to after my master I came
to us to present my research paper paper
because my research paper was accepted
in a nuclear medicine conference here in
Pittsburgh in 2007 so I was lucky now
but I was very excited like hey I want
to go America to for the research
because Indian research is is not that
great if you compare with the European
research or American research lab in
terms of you know experiments and and in
the machine and technology so I always
had a dream like I really want to come
for research so when I stay here for
like a few months during that conference
time I visited University and that's how
I got inspired like hey this world is
really different yes this is something
which I want to learn I want to explore
Ivan back and I did my GRE interface you
asked you on the way on this weight of
the story so you grew up in a place
where running water wasn't even
available to you yes and that is totally
different than how so many people grew
up first
yeah and so that in itself is like how
do we provide places in the world they
don't have running water with that at
least that basic necessity for human
life and then you went all the way into
moving to you know like you said your
three brothers you're coming up and this
is like it's hard to break through the
stereotypes and get to a bigger city and
go and pursue okay so in any rate about
nuclear medicine this is this is very
and then you were get accepted in
Pittsburgh to go and give your this is a
big deal so I want it I want to know
what how did you feel when you first
looked around in the United States yes
so the the so the funny thing then I was
I came to Ames when I was doing my
dissertation war thesis work one one of
my friend she was doing a medical degree
and she wanted to come here as a doctor
she said I want to go to us so that time
I didn't know where is us and what is
America actually that time it was in
2004 actually so so when into three
years she told me America and us is the
same which was really fun but I thought
oh wow this is maybe different world so
when I came here it's just like so good
because III witted Delaware University I
saw there like research lab and how
students life and they had like number
of opportunity they can stay in the
library for a whole night they have
access but in India its its opposite
your library is closed like a five
o'clock in the evening so you don't have
any access of the books but it names
it's 24 hours which I had a privilege so
everything was like really nice to me
like these guys are so lucky who are
studying here they have internet they
have
Bureau and the school looks like a
five-star hotel which we never had in
India did you hear that everybody lucky
we are yes yeah Internet 24-hour
Libraries things look like they're
five-star hotels like this is this is
the world that we live in in many places
in the United States and it's extremely
important for us to actually realize
that fully and be grateful for that with
all the opportunities like you listed
the labs of my quality doing important
research experiments yeah and
interesting that that was the first sort
of yeah so I if I compare here and in
India back in India so whatever we did
in the undergrad the fifth or eighth
grade students here they they do those
kind of experiments the one we did in
undergrad because our lab is very
limited we don't we do we do not have a
resources to perform the enough
experiment in our in our college degree
we are getting the chemistry or biology
or something used to have like you can
see but you can't touch something like
that in that in our lab but here you can
do whatever you want you can grow
whatever you want you can you have all
kind of axes all kind of chemicals you
are actually heading that laboratory in
your own own dream right in you can do a
number of experiments so this was like
you know when I went back and I did I
mean I start preparing the GRE and TOEFL
because that's what they needed for
graduate degree so within a one-year I
got my score and I started applying to
the schools so luckily I got it because
I cannot comfort the master degree I
didn't had money so PhD the only one
only thing that I can come and get a
scholarship and support for myself so
then I got a full scholarship in in
South Dakota and I came as a grad
students the School of Mines and Rapids
yes absolutely it's such a lovely place
and the true of my America I can see
there because yeah here I can see hybrid
but South Dakota is such a beautiful
beautiful place yeah in Rapid
is very beautiful in school mines is
located in a beautiful place the culture
is you have near Rushmore and there's
this totally different sort of vibration
in western South Dakota than it is in
San Francisco metropolis
totally different I'm glad that you've
seen these different varying levels from
rural India to you know a little bit
more rural South Dakota and then to you
know metropolis San Francisco and also
some metropolis India it's very good
that you've had these different yeah
experiences in life like okay so that
but what happened between School of
Mines to the su karma foundation how did
that happen yeah so it's School of Mines
actually uh after two years I drop out
the ph.d program because it was like a
some of my family issues I got married
and my husband was here in Bali so so
you know I had to move here and I had to
drop that school but I continued my
research in you know UCSF in cancer Bali
because back in India I was working in
the hospital Institute so Hospital
Institute means I was connected to those
patient I was directly working on some
kind of problem or the disease and back
in the South Dakota I was working on
engineering stuff because my degree was
in chemical and biological engineering
so most of the time I was solving those
thermodynamics problems and calculus and
all that so I didn't like that matt's
part so I thought okay let's start from
the hospital so I was lucky enough to
get in a UCSF as a senior research
position so I started in leukemia lab
hematology and oncology division under
dr. Karen Gensler and when I was working
there I did every year I used to go back
to my home back in India so whenever I
go back I I see like everything is
saying like school my school is same
the roads are same only you can get like
electricity is like in few houses not
like you don't have kind of a reader so
that you can you know people can get the
bail they just had a direct connection
so it's like that the life is still same
but if I live
I'm living here I'm looking the
different world and I'm going back and
those people are still suffering from
from so many issues even the girls in my
village they get married in 13 age age
of 13 days old 15 is still even I mean
the girls those who are born in my time
they have three four kids so that's the
life because they they don't have any
schools and and they don't have that
freedom so that they can you know pursue
their dream so that put me in thought I
really want to do something for my
village and also I'm the I'm the only
yeah I'm the only girl who came from
that village not only that village that
entire area to get higher education in
America so the people have back the
people have a high hope like this girl
went to America she's representing us
she will do some things to my village
yeah so whenever I used to go and and
people I used to ask like what you are
going to do for your village for your
people I didn't had any answer I thought
how much money I can give you guys I
cannot write I I'm a support maybe few
students few girls few people but I
cannot transform this whole village I
mean by giving the money right I had to
do something different to to make their
life better not only my village but
other other people in the similar area
right so then there was a moment called
like Anna Hazare movement started in
2011 which was like another form of the
Gandhi movement which he did in 1948 47
48 so then we had a high you applied we
really need to change the pillock Indian
electoral system so that we can remove
this corruption and get the better
government and better get the better
policy for the villages and the people
right now coming back year after year
and where are the increases in roads or
health or electricity or internet you
they were missing and you're wondering
what's going on with the money flow why
what's what is the holding it back and
it was corrupt officials yes so it's
it's a known fact like India and China
there
like equally corrupt even the more
corrupted India is more corrupted than
China just like a Pakistan and
Bangladesh exactly where would you say
they sit in terms of corruption to the
United States
so we're number one in in the United
States is number one on corruption real
selfishness
so United State I would say like the
lower-class I mean not even the lower
gate that the middle class people is not
suffering for the daily life daily life
means if he or she wants to do something
like a bank worth some official work
force for some some school work or some
hospital work they are pretty fair they
don't have to give a money to to anyone
to get their work done right but in
India if you are going to the bank
there's some government monies is is is
coming in your account so first you have
to give some amount to that bank officer
then he will give your money even it's
100 percent your money but you have to
give a bribe and you have to give a
bribe to the officials so so in that
phase you're fifty percent money is gone
and whatever is government issuing
anything for the road school or hospital
the I would say maybe sixty percent
money is coming to those work and rest
forty percent is is going in in a
corruption which is directly impacting
the middle class people yes in America I
think in upper class there are I mean
there is a big corruption but in at
least the lower class people have a
dignity they get a job they can do the
work and they can get get the facility I
mean at least water electricity roads
and infrastructure is there for everyone
yes and this is the like the basic
things that we need and we need for
everyday life we need a water we need a
clean air we need a clean environment we
need all kind of these facilities don't
need lady for the young women to not get
married when they're 13 but to choose a
path a different path yes yes yes
absolutely so if you compare America and
India we are like maybe hundred year bag
even though we are ruling the Silicon
Valley absolutely in terms of I'm
talking about the village life yeah yeah
but because Mumbai is like way different
right yes yes exactly
absolutely interesting okay so so now
let's continue down this path because
you were too hot yeah I was out the
corruption you're you made a book in a
documentary about this I wrote a book
Suraj you don't make a book you can
write you can write that say make as
well Rania okay write a book make a
documentary
yeah Swaraj moonkin hi yes okay so teach
us about Raja so when were when that
movement is going on that evolutionary
moment was going on I I thought I should
go and you know change the politics so
in that process I was working for that
party is called it's it's a new born
party called arm aadmi party so I was
working for that as a volunteer I was
managing and heading this chapter
Silicon Valley and during that process I
realized here there is a lot of
potential that we can bring the youth
and change this politics so but I always
had that dream hey I should be on the
ground I should see that excitement how
it is going and then in the in the 2013
November I thought okay I'm just leaving
my job and I'm just going for some time
to my village I want to see that you
know this how this electoral process
going on in my village so then I took a
tour of nearby villages where I see the
problem is so huge that you have you
really need good people here in politics
then I realized like I really need
something so I I was working as a
volunteer but the party gave me a ticket
it's called Member of Parliament just
like a senator election over here so
when I got that ticket people had a high
hope that you know we should we need a
good and young
any educated people in politics so that
we can have a better policy so in an
Indian Parliament right so so I when I
did those campaign I see similar problem
is everywhere
I lost election I came on third position
which I never declare it agreed because
it taught me a lot it connect me to the
worst people which I left like it 20 24
year ago and and I was learning those
things like how I can fix those problem
how can I fix those problems and where
is the ideal stuff then one of the guy
in Delhi he's another Gandhi and his
name is essential bara so I met him and
he said you know you belongs to that
village and there is another village
called burger bar it's such a dream
village where everybody wants to live in
that village and these those people they
transform that village in terms of ideal
sustainable and green village
so either really I didn't know I never
heard of that believed early next time
whenever you go you just check it out
and I went that village and those people
were so warm so loving and they shown me
like hey we developed this thing like
that just thing like that and I was
amazed to see that hey how many people
can come and see this village maybe no
one because you know it this village is
not not you know on the map or or in
this media or newspaper nobody knows
about this we'll even they got a
president award from Government of India
and also many other awards so then I
thought I need to do something I really
want similar village like my village
other village other thousands of village
in India really close to your home
village yes it's around 80 80 kilometer
which is like if it's very close yeah
it's very close so then I saw it as a
model City I saw a little model how the
model village look like in terms of
sustainability in terms of
religion religious things in terms of
communal harmony in terms of rainwater
harvesting in terms of education and
culture so so everything I saw in that
village so I requested them can I make a
documentary movie on your beliefs
because everybody cannot come to your
village but your village can go to
everybody in inform of the documentary
so they gave me the permission and then
I started making that movie I
I got a support from Silicon Valley I
mean my friends living here and I told
that idea to everyone everybody like
that and we made a documentary within a
year and making this document because
the purpose was that documentary was how
can we teach and educate the new
generation so that they will also think
about their own village their own things
and they should not migrate they should
create their own Kingdom I mean their
own own world wherever they are
basically so we need to bring the more
young people youth towards the the rural
India because you know everybody is
migrating then nobody is staying there
so the so who will come and fix that
because government is not doing anything
it's so hard because so much of the
opportunity exists in the metropolis is
yes because we awful networks are yes we
centralize everything like we are not
like decentralizing anything just like
Silicon Valley so so we used to scream
that documentary film to other village
to get inspiration like if we so show
that movie to other village then they
will also come up they said hey we also
want to make the similar village how we
will start so the problem was if we go
to other village there is no electricity
no TV no projector so how they will see
that it's I mean the next time right so
then the idea came what I mean if I can
write a book in their language how I
mean they can keep this book and also
read and also open whenever they want
and start working for the that village
because the movie if if I'm gonna give
in the DVD or flash drive they don't
have a computer they don't have TV how
they will watch right so the book
hardcopy
is
solution for that so that's why I wrote
a book and vscreen in many villages and
lot of youth came and said hey we will
definitely do something and also in
other villages of Rajasthan and there
are some village they started working on
the similar concept
so those village people they were very
very happy and an honored they said oh
you are the one who took our village to
the next level even the national
television they are showing the village
and even San Francisco we screened that
movie in Hollywood we screen that movie
and and so many other places so that
documentary and book were a catalyst for
more villages to come on to the grid in
more traditional farming electricity
friendly water friendly ways yes
absolutely so making that documentary
and the book I realized if I want to
work for a longer time I need some
organization I need something to to to
get some you know help and also
transparency because if I take people
money and now I spend nobody will give
me a next time right so then I started
su Karma foundation in India because
that's the easiest path part and I used
to I mean I wanted to work there but
after forming in in India I realized
nobody will give a donation there
because they always give a donation to
the temple to the religious things
nobody give for the community world so
how you will get funded then some of my
friend over here in Los Angeles and also
in Valley they said you need a 501c3
over here so that you can get the
support and start your new project then
we started here one and a half year ago
501c3
so now we are getting the support and
that's how the SU karma foundation born
which I mean then I started my dream
project was like a menstrual hygiene
stuff yeah so okay I love the story arc
is so good right now okay so I just for
me when I listening to you over the last
couple minutes have just been
envisioning a lot of rural places around
the world and just how much we really
just
have we just need to have more of a
stronger desire to go and help alleviate
some of the suffering that's going on
and make some of the processes a little
bit we have to increase the baseline of
living absence at least water and food
and shelter and electricity and health
care and education like that those have
to be their baseline keep going up
across the world and so I just I'm you
know you're a big inspiration to me and
so many others because you how you went
and actively work in that space and you
showcase that space and you make it more
relevant to people's lives thank you
thank you okay so now the sue Karma
foundation so this is this is a lot of
different components to it
you know awareness about menstrual
hygiene I actually when I saw the when I
saw that the tag I was so I was so I saw
I was so shocked because I didn't think
that you know you had you had the tag on
it was on unpaid woman I saw the tag
bleed with pride and this is part of you
know with suit with sue Karma as well
this this just just the notion that that
this is something that's usually very
taboo is bleeding with pride and this is
speaking about menstrual hygiene yes and
why is this is it's usually just this
time of transitioning to a teenager for
boys and girls where where boys are
starting to feel weird and girls are
starting to also feel weird and the
girls are starting to go through their
menstrual cycles and why is it taboo and
how do we stop making it taboo yeah so I
would I would add some of my story
because this is very intimate and
related to my own health that's why I
took this this topic and work on this
issue when I was growing up in the
villages I'm in the same village I
didn't have any idea because my mom she
never talked to me my school they never
told me about this stuff so when I had a
first period I felt very uncomfortable
at relative place so my aunt she gave me
the clothes and all that
the one everybody uses that and she told
me you had to go through this and
there's nothing and also I felt like
this is really pretty uncomfortable and
also very painful because you know you
don't have pads and you are you are
using those clothes and in in the rainy
season it's not dry then you had to use
that wet one and you cannot dry in front
of like direct sunlight you had to hide
and then dry so it's not hygiene it's
not sanitized and it is already causing
so many things so I was using that and
when I moved to New Delhi I was working
for the hospital I got an infection
some kind of weird infection so I went
to the doctor and doctor said what do
you use I said I still use clothes I
said why are you using that I said I
can't afford it because pad is so
expensive even though in the city then
she said you know what that's how you
got this bacterial or fungal or whatever
infection you need to stop using clothes
right now so then I realized are you
sure that came from that or maybe
something else I said that could be one
of the cause but we never we are not
sure but if you can stop that your your
your problem will be solved maybe sooner
so then I started using and I didn't
know how to use that stuff and all I use
in the wrong way those pads even I got
that I can afford it when I moved here I
still get that reoccurring infections
even when I was working in UCSF even
still even nowadays even it's like life
is very painful when I get those D
occuring infection so when I went to my
village I always like you know once in a
year I used to visit my village and I I
I said with those girls and and they
said they start complaining like you
know we had some kind of infection but
we can't tell to anyone
and then slowly those women they are
coming and saying oh we are getting you
know our uterus is removed because of
some some infection then it's all like
wow why this is
opening and then I I heard those news
like this many Aubrey's removed because
of these things and this is scam and
scandal and everything so either how can
I give this comfort life to those girls
because this is another issue where even
still nowadays my village you don't get
pad anywhere those girls they're still
using the same clothes things even
though it is it is a it is a market I
mean it is they're available nearby
villages or town but they can't afford
it because it is so expensive this
Proctor and Gamble in Johnson & Johnson
they are still making the pads and they
are selling to rural villages can you
believe like there's no local brand you
can find in India Wow we'll be back the
difference is your - there's a there's a
cloth a piece of cloth that you can take
and use that oh and then wash it and
then dry it like you were saying you
have to hide and stuff and then and then
you use that again or you can use the
pads that are single-use that are
sinistairs disposable single use pads
and that they're only there's no
manufacturing of single-use pads in
India I mean no local no effect on the
mass level yes so the so that's why
those pads are so expensive because
those big monopolies and the giant is
transporting and selling at the high
price so for 6-7 pads they cost around
forty rupees 250 rupees which is like
almost dollar one dollar one dollar for
how many pads for six seven pack some
pads yeah yeah that's a lot for this
large transfer do it really in six seven
pad is not enough for a 1p one time
periods you need more than that you may
need some time you need to pad so what
happened is like when those girls they
are not using I don't how can I provide
them affordable clean local pad local
and there was another thing is like
sometimes would happen is like we have a
farming I mean our area is mostly
farming area we have a two rotation of
crops so when the crop season comes the
women they all get job when it gone then
they are just sitting at home they are
not doing anything they don't have a job
so they are jobless and though at that
time they don't know what to do they
just end up they just end up doing all
those household stuff making manufacture
pads and yeah so so then to provide them
employment to provide them a clean pad
we come up with this idea how about
manufacturing the local pad and
employing all those employing and
empowering those women in in a paired
and and this hygiene stuff so then we we
again started this project
nine months they've had you've had
270,000 pads distributed and that's
that's a lot of people helped absolutely
yes yeah so so when I I got inspired by
this gay guys called I dunno chill a
Morgan Adam the pad movie came so when
we started manufacturing this the me are
you talking about what was his name
again I don't know I tell Morgan on tell
me yes he was just a local villager that
everybody thought he was crazy
yeah you design a piece yes very
familiar with that and that's great
that's that's good I'm known as the pad
woman of India he's pad man she's pad
woman he lost his wife didn't he yes
because she left him because she thought
he's a crazy I can't live with him she
was almost divorcing him because he was
crazy
he's not people the smart smartest
people in the world
craziest absent so I met that guy three
or bag I was very much inspired by his
TED talk it's still there tad it's like
six million views on on his dog
everybody watched it so I got very
inspired like this guy I really want
something like that similar idea three
year back and that was you know going
back on my mind and my other friends
also working on the similar stuff but
they didn't like you know extended their
their ideas but I will stick on that I
had to find the Machine I need to find
the budget I need to find the resources
to set up that
so last year I mean last year in
November we set up our first
manufacturing unit and that unit we are
we are manufacturing those pad and the
most important thing is so what happened
if you teach those women about the
hygiene they don't understand because
they never cared about like we need to
wash our hand again and again that
reduce like a 50% infection they don't
understand that but when they start
working in that facility they had to be
very clean they are working just like
just like a nurse like they are working
in the operation theater because they
had a nice dress they had a mask they
had a cap and everything and their hand
is very sanitized you can see the
pictures so so it's like they feel very
very happy and they understand about the
hygiene like hey if we need to work in
that clean way think about like you know
how how I mean we were working on the
wrong wrong stuff because we are using
dirty clothes that's not the good for
our health so now we need to teach our
daughter and now we need we need to
teach our community like a we need to
stay clean to avoid all those infections
so that kind of sense developed after
those women they walked in that facility
so and we also saw that movie called
Padma and they I took all those 50 women
in a one theater I reserved all that
theater and and all together be boys
that movie and they got this and so this
guy is really crazy he cared about his
wife so they they came back to home and
they were telling their husband like hey
you need to care about us in our
daughter because you know we we might
end up getting infection maybe sooner or
later so so that kind of stuff is is I
mean they called it and and and they
started working very happily actually in
that facility yes how did you start the
first manufacturing facilities how are
they now spreading yeah so the starlet's
so we had already team because I was
working on this movie and all that so we
are we are the like minded people there
I discussed that idea and one of our
volunteer his name is
Babulal so he gave us because we didn't
have enough resources and money to buy a
brand new shop so what we did is like he
give a give us his house like you can
open in this this area and we open in in
his area so that we can avoid the rent
and all that stuff and we started that
so so the idea is in India the fuel is
very expensive
anything you transport it costs more so
like if you're setting up your plant in
a big city and and you are transporting
everything to the village it will cost
more so the idea is why can't we install
the small unit so that the local people
can get I mean they can manufacture and
also it's easy to distribute because
it's a such a big taboo in India the
mill cannot go and distribute because
there's such a shy things I mean such a
they feel very very uncomfortable in
worker you will get who can do door to
door and all that stuff so it's a good
idea that we can install that facility
in in pretty much big village where you
can get all the electricity because
electricity is important those machines
are running with electricity so in that
area and it can cover entire 50 villages
one unit so it's easy to distribute in
those area and also we target schools we
target target girls hostel because girls
hostel thousands of girls living there
and and they they need those kind of
pads so that's the idea like we are
replicating those similar small-scale
unit and generating the jobs for the
women and also the hygiene awareness yes
it makes me feel great hearing about
this makes me feel like more healthy
across the planet more sanitary across
the planet it's easier for people to
pursue what they care about because they
don't have to worry so much of distress
so much and it's opening up opportunity
like you said for so many yes okay so
that is a lot of the SU karmis work now
I also want to talk about the the
medical kiosks as well this is this is
very exciting stuff so rather than
having to drive hundreds of kilometers
sometimes to a hospital facility now
teaches about the cure
yes so the kiosk concept I introduced
recently but before that this idea came
when I took this campaign it's called
pad woman on the wheel so you see the
pad women on the wheel means I I was
requesting all those people hey can you
come and do the campaign with me because
we need awareness so when I install that
fact unit is Factory I realize we need a
education we need awareness in those
areas in school and those girls because
what happened in Indian education system
we don't have any chapter of menstrual
hygiene till ninth grade ninth grade
right which is high school so when you
don't have any knowledge or or anything
how the girl will see what she need to
do when she had a first period because
her mom is not talking to her her
teacher is not talking to her nobody is
telling what is periods so when when she
didn't had anything she will definitely
get stress and she will she maybe get
anxious and depression like hey am I
going to have like cancer do I have some
disease experience this year yeah so the
bleeding yeah so the blue blood is
coming it means I had some disease so in
that kind of drama the girls gets really
scared and so we need awareness we need
some kind of information so that we can
reach out to those girls who are
entering in the poverty or about or they
are already in in one year so something
like that because there is no education
textbook or anything so coming up with
that that can
Payne what I did we created a nice
calendar which tells all the information
about menstrual hygiene because in India
what happened the period things you
cannot see anywhere like you cannot post
any poster and write it like a period
you cannot because the the girl feels
shy shy the boys feel shy and everybody
feel because it's a hiding things so
when they haven't seen anything then how
they would know so what I did like I
created a a post or a big banner I
displayed in my car SUV and I loaded
with this calendar and and other
educating stuff so there's a one cartoon
based movie period it's kind of so the
when you play the movie it is very
simplified tells everything about the
periods and what to eat what not to eat
how to clean and all that stuff so those
girls they they get that sense like hey
now we understand what we need to do we
don't need to scared and when I was
starting that campaign nobody wants to
come with me because it is such a shy
things
so me and my brother we both drove
around those 15 district thousands of
kilometer and we went and in almost like
we reached out 20,000 girls so when I
was I was doing that I realized people
they don't have a health care system in
their own village I mean from my village
if my family member or I get sick I had
to go hundred miles to just to take
injections or some medicine for for my
family member on so it's it's such a
really big thing you don't have any axis
of anything like a doctor or primary
health care so I I was in at ICON
conference like figure bath so I met a
guy his his company name is met on go I
think many of us heard about the Mahalo
clinic such a good model in New Delhi
where the Delhi government they they
implemented his idea to to install all
those kiosk in the small small area
basically in the within the city so that
they can reduce
traffic from the bigger Hospital because
what happened is when when people they
have some cold and flu they just go to
big Hospital super speciality hospital
which is causing the more crowd and more
pressure to those doctor where they
don't need those kind of treatment so
this kiosk what they do basically they
integrated all that technology and
medicine and doctor network so we can
put in the village and and also we can
train few local people like nm hmm
basically health worker so they can take
the blood pressure sugar and all that
test and they can send those tests to
the doctor who are sitting remotely in
any any city and they can see the
patient through the camera to the
computer and they can check the patient
and the patient can can get the medicine
within like 15 minute and he or she can
go to their home so in so putting that
kiosk will solve so many problem one is
that guy or or whoever is sick he or she
can come alone to that Center which save
other people other family member time
and also money and he or she can come
will not you know spend the whole day
which calls like thousands of rupees
when they go one city to another city
and you never know like doctor will will
call one time or sales or multiple time
so in one kiosk primary health care I
mean they will take care everything and
when they need to referral the doctor
can refer to the super speciality
hospital so this idea looks like very
health care that scales to the villages
around the world with professionals that
are there through video conversations
and then the local specialist that can
also take blood blood pressure anything
the doctor needs to diagnose and it
takes away from the lines and the big
cities and unnecessary visits to
specialists when they just needed a
physician all this kind of stuff
absolutely and burn most important thing
is so here in the medical system what we
learn is
once you go to the doctor your history
is recorded forever right so any
hospital you seeis have Kaiser or
anything but in India what happened is
when the patient go to the hospital they
they are given like some paper kind of
form where they doctor return something
and they come home and they lost it
because when they go second time they
don't have any history they don't know
what happened last time they don't know
what kind of medicine doctor gave us
this is also ties so this software will
write all the history will record all
the entire history on the families or
whoever and that can be used for ever I
mean what come in they can see all kind
of problems all kind of you know
solution in following those history
because then they don't have to ask
multiple times so basically this will be
creating a big death data for those
villages
I mean whoever is coming to that kiosk
which will solve I think the big problem
and where are the you're starting to put
the first one in your village in the end
of 2018 is the plan right yes okay yeah
so the idea is because you need a
trusted people and the team to start
these things so I only can get around my
area because that's where I will be
there I mean I mean most of the time if
it is successful and and and useful then
we can multiply to the other other
villages because my village connected to
four or five villages which they don't
have any health care systems so those
people also can access in my village
it's like few miles away yeah so then
another important thing would be to
figure out the hubs of villages so that
you can put one of the medical kiosks in
a place where multiple villages can
potentially come to yeah so we're you
know to figure out in 2019 where the
next ones should go is very so next next
one we will try to put like the most
remote and tribal area because when I
was taking that tour I identify most of
the villages
most of the area where I want to do some
certain project so definitely we can put
in the other districts so that other
people also can get the hell the most
important thing you need electricity and
the Internet signal yes because without
that you cannot run that cure so first
we need to identify where the tower
where the where the phone signal and
Internet signal is there and luckily we
are getting signal everywhere I mean
everywhere in India most of the villages
getting 2g 3G signal even though they
don't have water
I mean drinking water but they do have a
phone signal so what would you say are
the next big important items to make
action on for uplifting rural
communities in India the medical kiosks
continue hygiene awareness what are the
next big projects that society should
help focus and tackle for rural places
even around the world I think the I mean
our focus and the goal because I am from
a medical background I did my all all
time research and also that area I can
understand and I can address those
problems and they are also like very I
mean if you can see those people and you
see these problem we can fix easily in
terms of healthcare you can easily fix
them so that area is I mean that area
needs immediately because you know what
happened is like earlier time in even in
my village we never see any cancer
patient because the pollution I mean the
air and the water and the food was so
pure so nice that that nobody get used
to get sick but nowadays everything will
be polluted we are putting lots of
chemicals in our water we are putting
lots of pesticide in our food and that
is causing different problems I think
these area we really need to focus clean
water clean energy and also the clean
food that's the most important area and
together if because the people are
already suffering so you cannot leave
them alone
so you need to take care of them you
need to take care of their basic health
the the mental health and physical
health so that you know they can live
their life healthy life and also the
young generation because the state where
I come from you we have a maximum
malnourished kids maximum malnourished
it's ashes I think number one so we need
to take care of the the younger
generation so that we have a healthy
nation so in that in in in terms of that
situation you need to empower those
women you need to make healthy girls for
their futures and you need to prepare
the healthy generation yeah it's the
basic baseline once it gets increased
that then that those souls can then
actualize their full potential into the
world we just need to give them those
basic needs the tools or some resources
absolutely so yes my we like to end our
shows by asking a couple questions to
our guests do you is there something
else about uplifting rural India that
you want to share on the way out that
you think is important that we may have
missed well I believe in like if you are
uplifting the women the girls you are
uplifting the society and girl education
is one thing which I want to focus
because you know I'm that I mean I give
my example to the whole world because if
I am not educated I cannot do the rest
of the things so similar way the girls
they had a dream they have a potential
they have energy they have they are
intelligent but they don't have a
resources they don't have that freedom
their thoughts so we definitely need to
empower them to educate them too
to you know grow them so that any nation
can gain prosperous because of that
power yeah equality equality is a
biggest issue that we really need to
treat equal way as equal as boys because
I grew up in in inequality
not in my family but in the society
because when I went outside living alone
in the cities the community people they
used to complain to my parents like hey
you left your daughter alone you never
know what she's doing
she might be doing wrong thing or right
thing you never know
so that belief is not there so so
everybody's not like my parents
everybody's different they may pull of
pull out their girls and say you have to
make the food you need to learn the
family stuff your carrier is done and
that's how this what happened for most
of the families most of the girls even
my friend's childhood friends they all
end up their education because of of
that inequality yeah and what's up with
the 13 year olds getting married off yes
this is still going on ridiculous and
you know anything this is not property
it's not proper
you said you can't do anything no sure
you can well not killing people
well violence is the answer violence
well we can do a lot we can do a lot yes
yeah Lord we can we can you know educate
them we can make it we can give them an
opportunity we can give them that
believe that hey you need to go to
school and you need you have a right to
dream actually yes correct yep and but
there's a lot of people among us they
disagree with you Maya and don't ever
forget that and they're gonna die
thinking that that everything that you
say all the good things that you're
saying right now there are people among
us that disagree and they will use
violent oppression to make sure that you
stay in line and don't ever forget that
I want to wish you the best of luck
educating all the girls in India but you
know the peaceful protests and marches
never done [ __ ] for anything just
remember that absolutely yeah let's go
ahead let's get the questions and wrap
up the show before I get violent and
thank you on people this this section of
today's show has been brought to you by
the yeah there's a lot that you're
changing and I love that I love it too
yeah we both greatly appreciate it and
that's why we're having you on the show
to talk about and to inspire others to
care about it and make change - all
right do you think we are alone in the
cosmos I don't think we are alone we are
we are indivisible with with with our
own and also cumulative energy synergy I
would say that we have some force which
keeps us moving actually so we are not
alone we are like we are team we are we
are together to help each other but you
have to find that area of that energy
where you are hiding I'm sure everybody
have around them but they had to
recognize yourself
so together on earth but what about
outside of Earth is that I haven't
explored that one we talked about Moon
and Mars and everything unless we
explore because we need to fix this
earth first I mean I I I am a science
students I believe you know we need to
explore the other planet because we are
already polluting this we are already
polluted our ocean and earth but this
this planet is also beautiful believe me
this is so beautiful I have lived in the
rural most rural life and most urban
life which is the valley both have like
a I have no comparison but the beautiful
areas we can definitely fix some problem
over here and we can definitely
definitely uplift something from there
but we need to balance and outside the
earth you're more interested in Earth do
you think that this is a simulation
absolutely
yes tell me why because this is kind of
a like we are in the process where we
are you know making something learning
something doing something and coming
with the creative ideas thought to make
this life as a best or better life for
the other generation so I believe it's
it's definitely it is a simulation yes
because we go through a process of
learning and building and making it
better and glowing yes okay interesting
so we're like characters that are
leveling up and trying to make it better
for the next level the next generation
absolutely and that's what we I think
that's what our our idea should be
that's what we are born here that's why
that's what we came here because our
older generation they made something
they did something for us that's why we
are that's why I work that's why we are
using all those in order to use our next
generation we definitely need to do
something yeah and then what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world I think the beautiful thing is
nature in my because I love nature all
kind of stuff and I go and enjoy all
that stuff because I feel very connected
whether it is planned whether it is like
some mountains or water and the human is
another creator which I which I believe
like it's it's really beautiful with the
goodness if if we are destroying our own
nature being a human then we are not
good human we are not not yeah well all
the good people got to get off their ass
and start doing something and stop
acquiescing to the evil people among us
oh well there's not we can do it's the
law we have to obey it absolutely
because we are we are polluting
ourselves we are we are overloaded with
with the facility or with the comfort
that we really don't want to make any
travel to ourselves to to save our earth
for example we use straw of use plastic
we are using everything like single
things to be biodegradable within a
couple days it's biodegradable let's get
there even now we if we don't have
something like a bio didn't if we don't
have something like a biodegradable we
can reduce our our comfort right we can
you don't have to carry bottle there
like you don't have to carry bottle all
that all the time that plastic bottle
you just carry your own bottle like
steel bottle or whatever right that
gives a little uncomfortable
it is saving the planet you reduce your
your stuff you think about like okay am
i doing the good thing am i doing a
right thing am i stopping using this
plastic or this is harmful to my planet
mile you need to start loving your own
or plan then only you can you can
realize that thing it's treat like your
own baby yes yes and then only you can
look at ourselves in the mirror knowing
what we need to do to help keep Earth's
nature flourishing and plenty and love
for the next world next generations my
oh wow what a pleasure this has been
thank you so much so much for joining us
having enjoyed and such a nice sure
anyone thank you thank you think we
you're very inspirational to me Iran to
our audience and to so many people
across the world we hope to continue
helping with making the world better and
especially through you know uplifting
rural areas in the world increasing that
baseline across the world so we'll do it
together
and I always I always believe
that the education doesn't make a better
one education doesn't make a better one
education make us better and we make the
better one that's what I believe
everybody's educated but very few are
educated because they are doing better
thing for the world yes so I have to be
doing better thing with the world with
the education should get yes yes yes yes
it's little deep I love it thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it give us a comment below
let us know your thoughts about
uplifting real places in the world let's
get there together also check out the
links below to Maya's work definitely go
take a look at those and go support the
initiatives
thank you Ron for producing and
directing go and build Go manifesto
create your destiny into the world much
love everyone thank you and join us in
supporting us as well to help us scale
our impact all the information is below
for patreon click the currency you know
it thank you everyone
bye
you
[Music]